if you follow this channel you know that
many of these videos come from your
suggestions and i get emails all the
time from people who want content about
ufos others want lost cities strange
disappearances or
reptilian humanoids today we fulfill all
these requests in one video there is no
other place on earth steeped in more
mystery than mount shasta aliens ghosts
underground bases interdimensional
portals mount shasta has it all
let's find out why
[Music]
as you approach mount shasta the first
thing you notice is how absolutely out
of place it is though it's one of the
tallest peaks in north america it's not
directly connected to any other
mountains it stands alone and seems to
leap off the landscape at over 14 000
feet above sea level mount shasta is so
tall and steep that it pierces the
clouds and creates its own weather
located in northern california mount
shasta is actually a semi-active volcano
its last major eruption was in 1250 but
as recently as last year mount shasta
was oozing lava that caused several
fires in the surrounding forest and just
about every type of paranormal event you
can think of converges at mount shasta
ufo sightings mysterious disappearances
lost cities ghosts gods everything mount
shasta legends exist in every culture
that's lived in its shadow including the
first cultures native tribes have
inhabited the area for over 10 000 years
making it one of the longest occupied
areas in north america and each tribe
has a myth about the mountain some
tribes say mount shasta is the sacred
center of the universe others say the
mountain is the birthplace of all life
as different as these stories are there
is one theme found in every native
legend you do not go above the tree line
that area is reserved for the sky people
not far from mount shasta is petroglyph
point which has some of the oldest stone
writing ever found in north america
dating back thousands of years and the
glyphs depict the types of things you'd
expect to see animals rivers the sun
stars but there are also carvings of
what some people believe are sky people
native tribes believed that the sky
people were spiritual beings who existed
in a different realm a plane of
existence where souls and spirits of the
dead dwell but what if the sky people
aren't spirits of the dead but are
actually beings that are very much alive
just
not human
[Music]
there are native american legends that
describe a race of giants that live on
mount shasta the modoc have the matagami
which are said to be the keepers of the
woods could these ancient people be
describing bigfoot matagog me is the
monok word for bigfoot and it's similar
to the tibetan word metogongami which is
their word for yeti hey how do ancient
indians end up with the same word for
bigfoot well it would have to be some
kind of land bridge between india and
american wait a minute you're getting
way ahead of me on this one pal
we are oh baby
since at least the 1920s people have
claimed to see tall creatures roaming
the forests around mount shasta in 1976
a camper thought a park ranger was
investigating his camp but upon closer
inspection it was a bigfoot another
famous account happened in 1962 when a
hiker claimed to have seen a female
bigfoot giving birth oh that sounds
messy it does a lot of hot water tells
right i get it because if a bigfoot is
giving birth oh boy that's gonna be a
lot i said i get it
in 1930 a humanoid skeleton that was
over eight feet tall was discovered near
mount shasta and this wasn't a fringe
report it was covered by major
newspapers all over the area and native
legends say the race of giants prospered
on the earth for thousands of years but
were suddenly wiped out in a great flood
it always ends with a great flood
doesn't it
every time but there is an
interpretation of this legend that
claims the giants of the woods are not
bigfoot they're a race of people called
lemurians and that brings us to the
fascinating story of jc brown he's
considered the first person to find the
lost civilization of lemuria
but his story takes a mysterious turn
in 1904 jc brown was working as a
geologist for a gold mining operation
and he was sent to mount shasta to look
for gold during one of brown's
expeditions he came across a rock fall
that looked like something could be
buried underneath when he cleared the
rubble he discovered the entrance to a
cave that disappeared into the darkness
for what looked like forever brown hiked
the length of the tunnel which turned
out to be 11 miles long and that may
sound crazy but mount shasta is a
volcano and the entire area around the
mountain is a network of lava tubes lava
tubes can be huge and stretch miles
underground and when jc brown reached
the end of the tunnel he found what he
described as the remains of an ancient
city he found machinery long abandoned
that looked like it was used in a mining
operation he found statues tablets
shields and weapons all made of gold and
all inscribed with hieroglyphics he
found what he called a worship room with
statues that seemed to glow in the dark
and the final chamber of the cave system
was a tomb where 27 giant skeletons were
arranged and they ranged in height from
7 feet to over 10 feet tall unsure of
what to do jc brown covered the entrance
to the cave and told no one about it but
over the next few years brown became
obsessed with a book by james churchward
called the lost continent of mew and by
stories of lemuria which he thought
could be the same thing lumoria
according to the legend was an entire
continent that sunk beneath the ocean
many thousands of years ago
it's funny you should say that turns out
lamoria and atlantis are
connected in 1899 frederick spencer
oliver published a book called a dweller
on two planets which tells an amazing
story that was found written on ancient
hindu tablets over a million years ago
the earth was ruled by two very advanced
civilizations the atlanteans and the
lemurians and both cultures had
technology that far exceeds our own
atlantis was the dominant culture and
for many years it was benevolent but
about 25 000 years ago atlantis became
corrupt and wanted to rule all people on
the earth lemurians rejected this idea
and wanted to be left alone and after
much internal conflict atlantis decided
to go to war with the lemurians and for
years the two mighty civilizations
deployed devastating nuclear weapons
against each other the explosions were
so violent that they caused the earth's
tectonic plates to become unstable and
the magnetic poles to shift finally a
massive flood tore across the planet and
laid waste to both civilizations in all
60 million lemurians died atlantis
suffered severe losses as well the few
surviving atlanteans evacuated to agarta
an underground city that we'll be
covering on this channel the last
remaining lemurians fled to mount shasta
and established a city called telos
what's amazing is there's a hawaiian
legend that says the islands of hawaii
were once part of a vast continent
called mew also known as lemuria once jc
brown learned of these stories he was
convinced that he had found the lost
civilization of lemuria under mount
shasta so he decided now 30 years later
it was time to go back to the mountain
and when jc brown returned to mount
shasta he put together a search party to
help him rediscover lemuria brown had
assembled a group of 80 researchers
scientists and explorers and after a
thousand years of legend lemuria was
about to be proven real newspapers
widely covered the story and the
excitement around the adventure was
palpable then on the morning that the
expedition was set to begin jc brown
didn't show people combed every tavern
every street every inn looking for him
but they would find no trace jc brown
had vanished and was never heard from
again
explanations for jc brown's
disappearance covered everything some
said he was simply a fraud though he
never took a penny from anyone others
said a secret but powerful organization
learned of brown's plans and had him
erased illuminati yep but a few others
were convinced that jc brown no longer
needed a search party to find lemuria
but he had been granted access and taken
there by some mysterious machine and to
hear descriptions of this machine it
sounds like a vehicle or
right and there have been ufo sightings
around mount shasta going back over 100
years and in recent years sightings are
accelerating of the top 300 ufo hot
spots in the world mount shasta is
ranked 13th people have seen chrome
objects hovering above dark mountain
roads others report lights moving in
formation silently swarming the peak and
then disappear one of the most widely
reported ufo sightings happened in 2008
residents said they saw what looked like
a giant glowing jellyfish hovering over
the mountain eyewitnesses said it made
no noise but it seemed to have a fire
raging inside of it now unfortunately
there are no photos from the sighting
but just last year someone captured this
footage this happened
i'm sorry what is that there's a
passenger on the plane
looks out the window
grabs the phone this was filmed in june
the traveler sees that an object
apparently changing shapes in seconds
and what makes mount shasta ufos really
strange is that they don't just hover
around the mountain people have seen
them fly into the mountain and they
don't mean they flew into an opening in
the mountain every single person said
the ufos flew into the side of the
mountain and just vanished into the rock
it's been said that mount shasta is
hiding an energy vortex that allows
passage into another dimension locals
believe the ufos hide in the clouds and
enter the mountain through some kind of
portal but that begs the question
a portal to wear
[Music]
for decades eyewitnesses have seen
strange beings in mount shasta's caves
that seem to have the ability to walk
through walls they just vanish and it's
not just these strange beings that
disappear on mount shasta it's one of
the most active hot spots in north
america for mysterious disappearances in
2011 a young couple was camping on mount
shasta with their three-year-old son
suddenly the boy's parents looked up and
their son was gone they immediately
called the authorities and a massive
search went on for five hours then a
sheriff's deputy heard a quiet voice
coming from a bush not far from the
campsite this was odd because dozens of
trained search and rescue professionals
had combed every inch of this area
multiple times and found nothing but the
boy was found unharmed so this was
called a successful operation and that
was pretty much the end of it it wasn't
until a few weeks later when the story
would take a mysterious turn the boy was
talking to his grandmother who he called
grandma cappy about the incident he said
he liked this grandma cappy better than
the other grandma cappy who found him in
the woods whoa what yeah the boy's
mother was upset by this what other
grandma cappy the boy said the other
grandma cappy had taken him to a cave in
the woods there were other people there
too who were just frozen in place
and this new grandma seemed nice enough
but then she wanted to examine the boy
and for some reason she asked him to
defecate on a piece of paper
no he said he couldn't go yeah i'm a shy
pooper
but it gets even stranger grandma cappy
said that just a few weeks earlier she
was camping in the same area when she
blacked out then she woke up face down
in the dirt and noticed she had a
strange puncture wound on the back of
her neck she said she was violently ill
and thought it was some kind of spider
bite she was camping with a friend who
also had a similar wound and was also
terribly sick dna extraction well that's
one theory and grandma cappy said she's
never gone to that mountain again then
there's the story of karl landers in
1999 landers along with two friends set
out to hike to the summit of mount
shasta and along the trail landers just
vanished he didn't wander off he didn't
cry for help he was just gone and it's
not like he disappeared into the woods
or fell down a hole there was good
visibility for over a hundred yards
landers vanished in a wide open field
and he was an experienced hiker who knew
this terrain extremely well yet somehow
he disappeared off the mountain without
a trace and for a week a huge manhunt
searched every inch of the area the
national guard even sent helicopters
equipped with infrared sensors nothing
was found no equipment no clothing no
body all gone to this day there is no
explanation for what happened
so what's going on at mount shasta can
we use logic and science to explain
these mysteries well it's difficult to
explain ancient native legends because
we have no evidence to support or refute
the stories since the legends have been
passed down over several thousand years
not only is it possible but it's likely
that these stories evolved over time i
mean who can resist adding a little
drama to make a story seem more mystical
i'm guilty of doing it on this channel
mount shasta isn't a very active volcano
now but it's erupted many times in the
past and human settlements were present
during those eruptions when native
tribes described mount shasta as the
home of a god who throws flaming rocks
at his enemies we could certainly see
that these ancients were trying to make
sense of what they saw and when american
indians spoke of giants did they really
mean bigfoot it's not clear there isn't
much reporting of bigfoot until 1924
when a few gold prospectors came back
from an expedition talking about how
they were attacked by giant ape men who
threw boulders at their camp and the
story caught fire and grabbed so much
attention that park rangers launched a
full investigation what they found
didn't impress them they said the
boulders were actually just large rocks
and look like they were placed there by
the men and there were supposedly
bigfoot tracks in the area but when the
rangers looked closely at the tracks it
was clear they were made by one of the
miners using his knuckles and the palm
of his hand still there's no stopping a
viral story and the legend of bigfoot
was born but what about these portals
that seem to swallow people whole is
there any science to support the
phenomenon the two points in space can
be joined by nothing but energy turns
out there is
in 2013 nasa discovered a phenomenon
called an x-point x-points are places
where the magnetic field of the earth is
directly connected to the magnetic field
of the sun this is an uninterrupted path
of energetic particles leading from our
planet all the way to our star 93
million miles away another study
confirmed these portals and found some
of them are short-lived opening and
closing very quickly but others are
stable for long periods of time now
obviously we can't use these portals to
travel yet
yet but there is science to support that
the earth is magnetically tethered to
the sun and the magnetism around mount
shasta is highly unusual the entire area
is blanketed by an enormous negative
magnetic anomaly could this area of
strong magnetism be creating ruptures in
space that cause people to disappear
well that's a stretch
but if some kind of electromagnetic
event were to occur there are few places
on earth better suited than mount shasta
now the story of the missing boy who
suddenly reappeared five hours later
that's true the part about his grandma
cappy and the puncture in her neck
that came from someone claiming to be
her posting her story on the internet so
i don't know and the boy's parents
conveniently want to remain anonymous
but carlanders really did disappear
without a trace as have many people on
mount shasta most of the time missing
hikers are discovered not far from their
last known position usually dead from
injuries from a fall but it's worth
acknowledging that there are plenty i
mean lots of people who just vanish with
no explanation what about the ufos well
the ufo sightings can't really be
explained
weather around mount shasta is highly
unusual and creates what's known as
lenticular cloud formations and
lenticular clouds look like giant ufos
but they're just clouds as for it looks
like flying spacecraft hovering around
and disappearing into the mountains we'd
be silly to discount those reports even
our own government is finally admitting
there are objects zipping around the
planet that just can't be explained so
what about jc brown and lamuria well the
jc brown story is a great one but it
might be debunked in 2017 a researcher
named steven cendoni tracked down a man
named john benjamin bodie a mining
engineer who retired in mount shasta and
bodie had worked for the lord cowdery
mining company which was also jc brown's
employer and bodhi lived right across
the street from where jc brown had given
daily lectures on lemuria and the lost
city of telos this may not be definitive
proof that jc brown was a hoax but it's
pretty compelling research and i should
note that sindoni is not a debunker he's
a hollow earth researcher who's been on
countless tv and radio shows discussing
how the earth is hollow and home to
alien civilizations that live right
under our feet and speaking of hollow
earth what about lemuria is it hiding
inside mount shasta i think lemuria is
the best legend about mount shasta and
i'm not the only one entire religions
have been built around the lemuria story
in the 1930s guy ballard a mining
engineer was exploring mount shasta he
said he was met by a young man named the
count of saint germain and count saint
germain is a legend in paranormal
history he's supposedly immortal and
shows up during all kinds of historical
events there's even an account of him
being present at the signing of the
declaration of independence where he
actually gave a speech and we're to do a
whole video on saint germain he deserves
more attention but anyway ballard and
his wife edna claim to be the sole
messengers of saint germain and other
ascended masters as they're called the
ballards began giving public lectures on
saint germain's teachings and eventually
had grown the i am activity movement to
over a million followers
oh it's not and after ballard passed
away in 1971 most of the im members left
a religion but it's still around you can
visit the im reading room right now in
mount shasta city and lamuria and
atlantis were nothing more than stories
for hundreds even thousands of years but
with the discoveries like bimini road in
the bahamas and the yanaguni monument
off the coast of japan
we have to start wondering if these
myths weren't myths at all but actual
places skeptics will say bimini and
yanaguni are natural formations but i'll
put the pictures up for you to decide to
me bimini road is iffy i lean toward
man-made but i can see the other side of
the argument but yanaguni that looks 100
man-made to me so
what if
[Music]
mount shasta has captured the
imagination of people around the world
for centuries and those who visit often
say the mountain call to them i think
it's fair to say that if you're the type
of person who goes to a place expecting
to have a spiritual or supernatural
experience
there's a good chance you'll have one
the mind is a powerful thing but as long
as you're not starting religions based
on this i don't think there's anything
wrong with believing what others say is
a crazy theory our civilization's
greatest leaps forward come from
heretics who dare to challenge the
status quo from mavericks and dissenters
have come scientific discoveries that
altered the course of history and forced
even the most ardent skeptics to wonder
what if what if there was an ancient
civilization that sunk beneath the ocean
and what if the children of those people
are here now just waiting for our own
civilization to catch up waiting for us
to emerge from our selfish adolescence
so we can join a larger community one
that exists only for scientific
discovery artistic expression and
spiritual enlightenment now i admit it
sounds like fantasy but when we stop
asking what if civilization dies but as
long as there are heretics and mavericks
and dissenters we have a chance and if
you're one of those
keep asking what if
everyone on earth whether they know it
or not
is counting on you
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
subscribe comment like share all that
stuff really helps the channel trying to
defeat the youtube algorithm is like
trying to find the lost city of telos
but with your help we can find it
together until next time be safe
be kind
and know that you
are appreciated
[Music]
you